Ma mère n'avait jamais arrêté d’œuvrer pour moi,
de ma naissance à celle de mon fils.
Elle savait déjà ce que je commençais à peine à nommer.
L'amour est plus qu'une bouffée de sentiments
qui nous arrive si nous sommes chanceux.
L'amour est un doux travail.
Intense.
Sanglant.
Imparfait.
Qui donne vie.
Un choix que nous refaisons encore et encore.
Je suis une activiste américaine pour les droits civils
qui a travaillé avec des communautés de couleur depuis le 11 septembre,
combattant des politiques d'État injustes et des actes de haine dans la rue.
Durant nos moments les plus douloureux,
face aux feux de l'injustice,
j'ai vu les travaux de l'amour nous donner naissance.
Ma vie en première ligne du combat contre la haine aux États-Unis a été une étude
dans ce que j'en suis venue à appeler l'amour révolutionnaire.
L'amour révolutionnaire est le choix d’œuvrer
pour ceux qui ne nous ressemblent pas,
pour nos adversaires qui nous blessent
et pour nous-mêmes.
A cette ère de rage immense,
alors que les feux brûlent tout autour de nous,
je crois que l'amour révolutionnaire est l'appel de notre époque.
Si vous grimacez quand les gens disent : « L'amour est la réponse... »
Moi aussi.
(Rires)
Je suis avocate.
Laissez-moi vous montrer comment j'en suis venue à voir l'amour
comme une force pour la justice sociale
à travers trois leçons.
Ma première rencontre avec la haine a eu lieu dans une cour d'école.
J'étais une petite fille grandissant en Californie,
où ma famille vivait et avait une ferme depuis un siècle.
Quand on m'a dit que j'irais en enfer car je n'étais pas chrétienne,
traitée de « chienne noire » car je n'étais pas blanche,
j'ai couru dans les bras de mon grand-père.
Papa Ji a séché mes larmes --